I feel like you don't want us to win
yeah you're against us I bet you thought
we were gonna be dummies turns out we're
not so stupid
[Music]
hi I'm Will Ferrell I'm Jason Mantzoukas
and I am Amy Poehler and we are here
today because we are going to take a
standardized test
a woman else yeah you go ahead okay the
relationship between whisper and scream
is the same as the relationship between
thunder and lightning breeze and tornado
light and dark Cagney and Lacey no sorry
dee is sweet and candy I think you have
to write yours down - I do
Yeah right oh you don't have more
information than we'd like legit oh I
[Music]
first I put D and I scratched it out and
saw everyone else pick B correct answer
is B that's right yeah which of the
following is a city in Austria Salzburg
wind passing what Jesus Jesus is one of
them no but you'll hear why I say that
option C is D all of the above this is
kind of a joke question it's literally
[ __ ] and wind passing could be a wind
passing city in Austria that isn't Vince
missing Vince I see oh you know I did
semester of Rod and VIN passing passing
and vision Oh Sookie I'm in last place
assumed you guys know you doing well I
think I've gotten everyone right nice
job chase Jason you are in Mendte yeah
sure
but not the metaphor genius by the men
is it like it's men's a it's men so
warehouse you're gonna love the way look
which part of the cell is commonly
referred to as the powerhouse of the
cell or as I like to refer to as the
Dwayne rock Johnson of
sell is between the rock Johnson in the
movie the house go to the theaters if I
met when Ron Jackson is not in house was
that song from legal Dwane Roger oxygen
uh troopers doesn't at all okay
the powerhouse itself the nucleus the
cytoplasm goal goalie apparatus D the
mitochondria hmm Golgi apparatus is my
high school band man shall we answer it
[Music]
[Music]
we tele the scores and Jason yes yeah
he's in he needs it does anyone have a
tranquilizer gun I did it I get it